this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about the main cause of carpal tunnel
syndrome in 35 and unders
swiping on dating apps if you're looking
for love online chances are you've
racked up a fair share of heartbreak or
at least mild disappointment while
offering a seemingly infinite supply of
potential suitors dating apps can feel
like an endless cycle of swiping forced
witty banter awkward coffee dates mutual
ghosting and ultimately going to bed
alone so how did we get here is online
dating a unique technosexual dystopia or
the natural culmination of centuries of
courtship rituals let's find out in this
wisecrack edition online dating is love
just a commodity but before we dive in i
want to tell you about this week's
sponsor keeps keeps makes it easier for
guys to prevent hair loss with their
affordable prescription service you can
maintain the hair you have with
convenient at-home treatments the
process begins with a free consultation
with a licensed keeps doctor who can
recommend a combination of fda approved
prescriptions and over-the-counter
medications that's right for you these
hair loss prevention medications will
land at your door every three months so
you don't have to dedicate any brain
space to remembering refills as your
treatment plan goes on you can message
your keeps doctor 24 7 to update them on
your progress and ask any questions you
may have it typically takes between four
and six months to start seeing results
so get started today to hang on to the
hair you have go to keeps.com wisecrack
or click the link in the description to
receive 50 off your first order that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash wisecrack now
back to the show to contextualize the
modern dating scene let's look to
history for much of dating history
heterosexual courtship was all about
getting a ring on that finger most women
weren't allowed to work and thus sought
financial stability via marriage while
men were incentivized by that sweet
sweet dowry what's wrong with her she's
beautiful she's rich she's got huge
tracks of land courtship was largely a
private enterprise arranged between
families with women essentially
functioning as bartering tools to
solidify social alliances potential
candidates were evaluated based on class
and social status sociologist eva elus
also notes that most young people were
pressured to accept their first
reasonable option love was nice if it
happened but this was mostly a
regimented transaction not all of us can
afford to be romantic
i've been offered a comfortable home and
protection
there's a lot to be thankful for
i'm 27 years old
i've no money and no prospects but then
in 1840 queen victoria and legendary
wife guy prince albert entered the chat
for me this is not the marriage of
convenience
no
i think it will be a marriage of
inconvenience they were famously head
over heels and love a romance that only
got more legendary when victoria
publicly mourned albert for 40 years
after his death royals as you may know
were basically the original influencers
so this romance coupled with the
mainstreaming of enlightenment ideals
about personal fulfillment helped make
marrying for romantic love start to seem
important and even noble for upper class
women this era of courtship meant
suitors leaving calling cards and
arranging chaperoned meetings like
bumble but your frowning stepmom is also
there just just sitting and and judging
what's important is that courtship now
entailed assessing compatibility between
families personalities and so on rather
than just settling for the first joe
shmoe who threw a stone at your window
working class women somewhat empowered
by the wage economy were less bound by
ceremony and often lived in apartments
too small for men to come calling anyway
they met men on their way to work in
shops or at music halls they dated had
sex juggled a bevy of admirers and it
wasn't uncommon to be pregnant on your
wedding day dating around wasn't just a
fun time it was also considered
essential to finding the right match and
what elus calls the emergence of a
self-regulated market of encounters but
here's the thing in the dating culture
that emerged at the end of the 19th
century money became even more central
to the direct interactions of the couple
because now dating meant going on dates
and going on dates tends to cost money
as scholar beth l bailey explains
courtship was largely construed and
understood in models and metaphors of
modern industrial capitalism as dates
moved from living rooms into dance halls
and bars money was what bayley calls a
symbolic currency of exchange where men
needed to pay to gain access to women's
company by the 1920s she notes dating
provided a new frontier for public
competition through consumption as a
result young people started defining
themselves as commodities men by how
much they could afford to spend on
theater tickets women by how much they
were worth spending on this fittingly
coincided with the explosive growth of
the consumer economy which transformed
ideals of romantic love if men now
needed to have money to burn on
vaudeville shows women
now needed to look like pre-war
kardashians that's in large part due to
the increased sexualization of women in
the media and advertising industries
like cosmetics relied on enticing
imagery to create demand for new
products as illus notes before the 1920s
the word sexy was actually considered
derogatory it was more preferable to
shack up with someone who was say super
moral or reliable but as mass media
began pumping out images of eroticized
female bodies and soon enough male
bodies sexual attraction began figuring
into people's choices in a much bigger
way as marital selection became
increasingly less based on your social
status and more on subjective things
like sex appeal the ability to land a
regulation hottie started factoring more
into people's conceptions of individual
self-worth as illus puts it under
modernity sexuality thus becomes closely
intertwined with social value but of
course nothing spoils the sex party
quite like a pair of world wars couples
were split apart with courtship
relegated out of the dance hall and back
to the post office but it went beyond
these basic logistics the idea of a
chaste woman who stayed home loyally
awaiting the troops return became hugely
popular especially during world war one
and that chaste woman became something
of a commodified trophy for men down in
the trenches to fantasize and sing about
my girl back home
i'd almost forgot
a blue-eyed kid
i liked her a lot while the fellas were
away working-class and middle-class
women also spent more time in the public
sphere doing man stuff like going to job
and sometimes wearing trousers
but especially after world war ii the
return of the troops plus rising
pressure to marry early pushed a lot of
women back into the home some of the
rush to get married was out of anxiety
about the scarcity of eligible men
post-war which reinforces a marketplace
vibe but this also had other important
economic implications whereas married
women had once been treated like pure
commodities housewives were now the main
consumers of commodities men went to
work produced goods accumulated capital
and their wives spent that money buying
more goods thus the marriage industrial
complex became vital to keeping the
consumption-driven 1950s economy humming
meanwhile for the burgeoning youth
consumer culture of the 1950s go and
steady became a coming-of-age dating
ritual in its own right complete with
varsity pins and a sexy game called two
straws one milkshake
[Music]
by the mid-1950s one in ten middle
school students would go steady at least
once before turning 11.
of course i better than double those
stats myself
going steady is essentially the origin
for how we conceive of dating today in
all its cereal monogamy and make no
mistake just as it was for their parents
consumption was inextricable from this
boom in young love shopping and
investment became metaphors for dating
you needed a car to neck in a class ring
to exchange a letterman jacket to drape
over your date's shoulders records to
dance to and turntables to play them on
meals at the malt shop and so on and
dating remains a consumption driven
activity to this day
even if we've swapped banana splits for
charcuterie boards and class rings for
netflix passwords now the 1960s and 70s
as you probably know brought varying
degrees of free love and rebellion
against the previous decades sexual and
romantic constraints but by the 1980s we
saw our return to conservative values in
pretty much every element of american
society it's around this time that the
1950s were reimagined as a nostalgic
utopia of happy families born from
people who'd just lost their virginity
the free market obsessed 80s also saw
the ascendancy of dating technology like
computer-based dating services or the
truly heinous video dating boom hi i'm
maurice i'm an executive by day and a
wild man by night these companies
promised to help you say do comparison
chopping of potential dates from the
comfort and privacy of your own home
again we see the language of capitalism
continuing to permeate dating and then
came the internet now technically the
earliest version of computerized dating
came from harvard in 1965 when some
students created operation match a half
century before your favorite sunscreen
enthusiast who would start your least
favorite social networking site in hopes
of getting laid this 75 question long
survey helped tens of thousands of
people learn about well-suited potential
new mates in its first year alone and
its algorithmic match process has since
been emulated by modern dating sites
these companies also used the knowledge
gained from those questionnaires to mine
consumer data a practice that would only
grow in the years to come as the
internet entered more homes companies
like aol funneled people into chat rooms
bulletin boards and so on based on
mutual interest which inevitably led to
dating the first dating site kiss.com
launched in 1994. followed shortly
thereafter by match.com in 1995 and by
1998 nora ephron made the world a better
place with the film you've got mail
sidenote we actually made a video about
how that delightful film is secretly
fascist so check it out now early online
daters encountered plenty of stigma and
were often painted as desperate but the
more online our lives have gotten the
more mainstream online dating has become
by 2007 americans alone spent 500
million dollars on online dating
services making it the second most
profitable sector of the internet
economy and and we all know what the
highest industry is
the one when you have to open up the
anonymous browser to go look at so it's
not in your history so that if your mom
uses your computer that thing doesn't
happen again like it did that one time
so it comes as no surprise that online
dating services are expected to rake in
over 3 billion dollars this year in the
united states alone especially in light
of how a cornucopia of new dating sites
and apps have cropped up boasting new
innovations like tinder's gamified
swiping interface or bumble's woman-led
dating model a benefit of online dating
is the way it creates opportunities for
people from specific communities to
connect with each other lgbtq plus folks
people in rural areas elderly or
disabled people health even fly
fishermen it can also be a relatively
unthreatening way to meet new people and
sometimes to screen out potentially bad
matches but we see something else going
on that we think does a lot to explain
why online dating can feel so hard and
occasionally pretty depressing now we've
talked about the intersection between
dating and economics from dowries to
theater dates to the consumer demand for
engagement rings that cost a month's
salary but we'd argue that online dating
basically takes the commodification of
the actual act of dating that cropped up
around the turn of the century and
turned it up to 11. put it up to 11
exactly how well as scholars rebecca d
hino nicole b ellison and jennifer l
gibbs note in their article relation
shopping dating sites are typically
designed like online shopping platforms
evoking the sensation of literally
window shopping for a match they write
that the functionality and design of
online dating sites encouraged
participants to adopt a marketplace
orientation towards the online dating
experience now that doesn't necessarily
make tinder sinister but it could have
real implications for the kinds of
relationships you're most likely to find
in relation shopping the authors write
that online dating may encourage an
attitude where prospective partners are
commodified as products to be sold
assessed purchased or discarded being
discarded is probably fine if you were
only looking for a one-time hookup but
it lends a depressing heir if you're in
search of a long-term relationship ilus
notes that it also leads to
hypercritical assessments that render
potential partners commensurable
measurable and comparable with each
other and if sexual attractiveness
became a big deal in the 20s it's only
been magnified in importance because
these apps facilitate a lightning-fast
superficial decision-making process
typically based on a few flattering
photos online dating also massively
expands your pool of potential matches
creating a sense of interchangeability
how many daniels can you match with
before they all blend into the same guy
in cargo shorts and this replicates the
overall sensation we have as consumers
today where we're similarly empowered to
choose between a dizzying array of 125
toothpaste brands what's more in the
logic of online dating potential matches
are reduced and scrutinized by isolated
attributes making them easier to reject
or discard research has found that the
ease of discarding online dating
partners may even continue into a
relationship that's partly because of
the lack of an integrated social
environment i.e shared friends or
communities which makes it feel easier
to ghost overall illus argues internet
dating sites display the consumerist
logic of increasingly narrowing defining
and refining taste and comparing among
alternative possibilities while it's
obviously good to be picky when it comes
to choosing a long-term partner applying
consumerist logic to actual human beings
seems less picky more icky and it's not
just your potential dates that are being
commodified here the authors of relation
shopping also note that online dating
encourages self-commodification
via a tangible and explicit assessment
of one's own perceived desirability in
ways less likely to occur with
traditional face-to-face communication
that is to say participants in online
dating are constantly receiving reams of
data that cause them to assess their own
objective value in the dating world
which can feel pretty
harsh so what does this all say about us
well modernity ilus explains has been
all about the rise of the rational in
just about every aspect of life from
psychology to weight loss fats online
dating reflects the rationalization of
love where we're encouraged to assess
potential dates as laundry list of
attributes rather than messy complex
human beings the endless supply of
consumer choices that defines late
capitalism has been effectively mapped
onto human relationships while some of
us may romanticize the 1950s model of
going steady long term the tech we're
using to find relationships may be
counterproductive in achieving that goal
think about it after world war ii women
settled into marriage quickly due to the
scarcity of eligible men in contrast the
seeming abundance of matches provided by
online dating might incline us to not
settle down at all or to discard a
potential mate simply because there
might be a shinier object just a click
away don't get us wrong exploring your
options is great but when it's treated
like the same process as finding the
right netflix show it starts to feel a
little
cynical and the commodification of human
beings on dating sites goes even deeper
hinge might brand itself as the dating
app designed to be deleted but it's
actually in all the apps best interest
to keep you scrolling through face after
face and their casino style interfaces
make it all too easy to waste an evening
doing just that ultimately these
companies make a great deal of money by
collecting super valuable data about
some of the most intimate aspects of
your life after all these aren't old
friends interested in helping you find
love there are tech platforms interested
in earning a buck or a billion of them
so it seems that dating has become more
complicated and more commodified than
ever before finding a mate a prospect
once simply determined by your family's
financial capital is now an important
means of affirming your worth of
broadcasting your individual social and
or cultural capital qualities like your
sense of humor or your great hair ilu
says they'll start to become indexes of
your inner value in other words if you
used to be able to blame your bankrupt
dad for hurting your chances of landing
a wife now you're implicitly told to
blame yourself for not being witty
enough in your about me section so what
are we supposed to do we're years off
from designing our perfect partner in a
lab free love communes are harder and
harder to find and sex robots can be
hacked and turned into murderbots so are
we stuck as self-aware commodities in an
ever-expanding marketplace of
increasingly disposable romantic
products well barring some kind of
cultural backlash online dating will
probably keep becoming increasingly
intrinsic to our courtship rituals we
can't change that but maybe recognizing
the unusual historical moment of dating
that we're in can help us be a little
less hard on ourselves when the process
feels hopeless and maybe thinking about
how weird it is to treat yourself like a
commodity can almost be a little less
judgmental towards men who post photos
of themselves with tigers because at the
end of the day we're all looking for
some iteration of the same thing human
connection whether for a night or
forever well that and romantic partners
who look like they're auditioning for a
tiger king biopic but what do you guys
think do you wish your romantic life was
still determined by dowries is online
dating killing romance or is shopping
for dates fun and empowering let us know
in the comments big thanks to our
patrons for all your support and be sure
to check out our podcast hit that
subscribe button like it's a super like
on tinder and don't forget to ring that
bell and as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shout out to all my soldiers online
dating actively it sounds rough bring
back arranged marriage okay here we go